the guy from Twilight's in a movie where
he falls in love with a girl and has to
take her away from her life that's what
we call acting range Water for Elephants
now Water for Elephants is a romance
with a formula that you've seen a
hundred times over it was some really
intriguing elements the movie starts out
in modern times this old dude and this
young dudes start talking this old dudes
like oh yeah I used to be in this circus
I'll tell you the story and the young
dudes like yes I would love to hear that
story old guy amazingly enough they fit
an old guy story into a two hour movie
that's never happened to me ever and his
young self is played by none other than
Robert Pattinson chorus story goes
Robert Pattinson 'he's character was on
his way to being a veterinarian when
tragedy hits his life and he comes
across a circus in which he's like i'll
be a carnie why not then he meets Reese
Witherspoon who's married to the boss
played by the Jew hunter Christoph Waltz
and you know that guy's gonna steal the
show and he absolutely does it's almost
a cliche now to say Oh Christoph Waltz
stole the show he was the best part but
he was and he did because the guy was
just really unstable even in his calm
moments you're just waiting for him to
lose his then he starts talking and
starts drinking the tension Rises and
you're just waiting for it to happen
you're waiting for him to just snap it's
intense and the guys are really
good actor and yes there are a lot of
moments where Christoph vols loses his
and girls if you're with a guy in
which you need to make excuses for him
like oh he gets that way when he's drunk
just leave him lessons from movies words
from me how we roll here but Robert
Pattinson Reese Witherspoon's chemistry
I I didn't feel like they were like in
love I felt like she was a chick who was
married to this dude so she sees this
new pretty face come in he's kind of
infatuating for her so she just kind of
has a crush that's it nothing big
nothing you know real again you feel
like you've seen this a hundred times
over it had some cool elements in the
movie had some really cool conflict in
the movie it also had boring parts in
the movie and no chemistry between the
main actors however Christoph falls in
the elephant they had chemistry so is it
a better romance based around a circus
than Batman Returns no I would say it's
okay but you're not gonna remember it in
t-minus being single I'm just saying
this movies clearly meant for chicks
single guys I don't know why you would
go to this movie not your thing I
promise however lessons can still be
learned from romantic movie starring
like the Twilight guy guys out there
never let your wife have a business
relationship with anyone who looks like
Cedric Diggory it's not gonna be good
for you chicks are like powerless
against that face but if you like what
you've seen here and you want
Seymour click right here to see more